Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update we haven't seen or heard from
Final Fantasy 15 in quite some time but
now news of a demo has surfaced and it
could be available as early as March a
report from Game Informer revealed that
copies of final fantasy type-0 HD will
come with a voucher that allows users to
download a demo of Final Fantasy 15 for
free it will allegedly be available for
both PlayStation 4 and Xbox one but
though type-0 HD is scheduled to come
out in March of next year no mention has
been made of the demos Times Square Enix
has named the demo episode dust guy dusk
a deuce game dusk I do skate and it is
said to include some opening sections of
the game partly altered to fit the
shortened format gamespot has reached
out to square enix and will provide you
with updates if we hear anything we may
also hear more about Final Fantasy this
weekend as the Tokyo Game Show is
getting underway and gamespot's got some
of its best folks over in Japan to cover
it for more of the up-to-date gaming
news from Japan the u.s. and the whole
inside world go to gamespot com / news